CONSERVATIVES THREES THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
NEARLY 30 YEARS AGO, DINESH
DUES WROTE A BOOK CALLED A
LIBERAL EDUCATION.
IT DESCRIBED IN LURED DETAIL
HOW ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES THE
AMERICAN LEFT HAD GONE FROM
CHAMPIONING FREE SPEECH TO
STIFLING IT.
CONSERVATIVE UNDER REAGAN A
POTENT FORCE.
A PATRIOTIC ALTERNATIVE TO
THE MALAISE AND PESSIMISM OF
THE 1970S.
THE FACT KUEHL AT THIS AND
THE ADMINISTRATION OF
ADMINISTRATION OF CAMPUSES
BECAME DOMINATED BY LIBERALS
DESPERATE TO TURN YOUNG
MINDS AWAY FROM REAGANISM IN
THE AMERICA HE REPRESENTED.
WITH THESE ACTIVISTS
MAINTAINED, LET'S FACE IT AS
INHERENTLY RACIST AND
SEXIST, BECAUSE ITS FOUNDERS
WERE PRIVILEGED WHITE MEN.
CONSERVATIVES CHALLENGING
THE LIBERAL ORTHODOXY ON
CAMPUS WERE SUED, MALIGNED,
AND THEY WERE MALIGNED BY
STUDENTS AND PROFESSORS
ALIKE.
THEY WERE SUBJECT TO
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AND EVEN
PHYSICALLY THREATENED.
THE ULTIMATE GOAL WAS TO
BULLY THEM INTO SILENCE.
OF COURSE, THAT EFFORT
FAILED.
CONSERVATIVES PROBABLY NOW
SEE HOW NAIVE IT WAS TO
BELIEVE THAT THIS SQUELCHING
OF FREE SPEECH WOULD END
ONCE THEY LEFT CAMPUS.
INSTEAD, THE LEFT'S
PROPAGANDA SHAPED A NEW
GENERATION OF YOUNG ADULTS
WHO THEN PAIR ROUTED THAT
YOU WILL MALARKY ABOUT THE
PATRIARCHY AND
MICROAGGRESSION AND SAFE
PACES AND SAFE SPACES.
TODAY THEY USE THESE TERMS
AS BLUDGEONS TO INTIMIDATE
THOSE WHO DISAGREE WITH THEM
FROM ENTERING THE DIALOGUE
AT ALL.
SO FOR ALL THEIR TALK OF
INCLUSION, THE LEFT DOESN'T
INVITE MORE VOICES TO ENTER
THE PUBLIC DISCUSSION.
INSTEAD, THEY DRIVE OUT ANY
DISSENTING VOICE AND POLICE
THE DOGMA OF THEIR OWN
CREATION.
GENERATIONS LATER, THE
CHILLING EFFECT ON FREE
SPEECH AND THE WORKPLACE IN
LARGE IS PALPABLE.
WE ALL FEEL IT.
AND THE SITUATION MAY BE
WORSENING.
A BROOKINGS INSTITUTION
SURVEY WAS RELEASED LAST
FALL OF COLLEGE STUDENT'S
ATTITUDES TOWARDS FREE
SPEECH ON CAMPUS WAS REALLY
DEPRESSING.
THE RESEARCHERS ASKED DO YOU
AGREE WITH SHOUTING DOWN A
CONTROVERSIAL SPEAKER WHO
COMES TO CAMPUS?
51% OF RESPOND DENTS SAID
YES.
AND DEMOCRATS WERE FAR MORE
LIKELY THAN REPUBLICANS TO
AGREE WITH STIFLING FREE
SPEECH ON CAMPUS.
62 TO 38%.
AND BY THE WAY, WOMEN WERE
MORE LIKELY THAN MEN TO
BELIEVE THAT SO-CALLED HATE
SPEECH IS NOT
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED.
THE NUMBERS WERE 49 TO 38%.
AND BY THE WAY.
OTHER DATA INDICATE THAT
HOSTILITY TO FREE EXPRESSION
IS STARTING EVEN EARLIER
THAN COLLEGE.
MEANING THESE KIDS ARE
PICKING IT UP EITHER AT HOME
OR IN HIGH SCHOOL, JUNIOR
HIGH OR IN BOTH PLACES.
THIS, TOO, IS SUPER
DISHEARTENING.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT ALL OF
US, REGARDLESS OF WHERE WE
FALL ON THE IDEOLOGICAL
SPECTRUM, RECOGNIZE THE
PERILOUS ROAD THAT WE ARE
ON.
THINK ABOUT IT IF 40 TO 50%
OF THE COUNTRY FEELS LIKE
THEIR RIGHTS TO FREE
EXPRESSION IS LESS WORTHY OF
PROTECTION THAN THAT OF ANY
GARDEN VARIETY LEFTIST?
WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE OUR
FIRST AMENDMENT?
AS A SHELL OF ITS FORMER
SELF IS THE ANSWER.
THERE IS A CONTRACTION OF
FREE SPEECH AROUND US.
FEW SEEM TO EVEN NOTICE.
MANY OF YOU HAVE BECOME
ACCUSTOMED TO EDITING
YOURSELVES.
LET'S FACE IT EXPRESSING
VIEWS THAT JUST FIVE OR 10
YEARS AGO WERE CONSIDERED
MAINSTREAM CAN NOW GET YOU
FIRED.
IT CAN CAUSE TO YOU LOSE A
PROMOTION.
OR YOU COULD BE BRANDED A
HATER.
OR, YES, YOU CAN GET
BOYCOTTED.
SADLY, WITH PEOPLE LIKE
CHRISTOPHER HITCHENS AND
MATT HINTOFF GONE.
THERE ARE A ONLY A TRUE
LIBERALS ON THE SCENE TO
EXCHANGE THE VIGOROUS
EXCHANGE OF IDEAS.
>> I HAVE BEEN THE VICTIM OF
A BOYCOTT.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> I LOST A JOB ONCE.
IT IS WRONG.
YOU SHOULDN'T DO THIS BY
TEAM.
IT IS THE MODERN WAY OF
CUTTING OFF FREE SPEECH.
>> Laura: AND THE GOAL POSTS
BY THE WAY ARE FOREVER
MOVING.
EVERY DAY MORE ISSUES ARE
TAKEN OFF THE TABLE ALL
TOGETHER AND MAY LONGER BE
DEBATED AT ALL.
SO, IN OTHER WORDS, IF YOU
ARE AGAINST AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION.
YOU ARE A RACIST.
AND IF YOU WEAR A MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN HAT TO A
GUN CONTROL RALLY AND GET
BEATEN UP, WELL, DON'T
EXPECT A LOT OF SYMPATHY
FROM THE ATTENDEES.
AND IF YOU PRAISE THE
MILITARY SKILL OF ROBERT E.
LEE, YOU ARE LIBEL TO BE
BRANDED A DEFENDER OF
SLAVERY IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES."
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED
DURING THE CAMPAIGN WHEN
SOMEONE LEFT WING NUT CASES
IN SAN JOSE GOT THEIR HANDS
ON A TRUMP SUPPORTER?
THIS IS THE INTOLERANT LEFT
IN ACTION.
WHETHER IT'S STRIKING VOICES
FROM SOCIAL MEDIA, OR
DRIVING CERTAIN VIEWPOINTS
ON THE AIRWAVES.
BEATING PEOPLE UP,
ORGANIZING BOYCOTTS, FOR
PERCEIVED UNFORGIVABLE
OFFENSES OR PREVENTING
SPEAKERS FROM BEING HEARD ON
A COLLEGE CAMPUS, IT'S ALL
COMING FROM THE SAME PLACE.
A DESPERATE DESIRE TO STOP
DEBATE BY BRANDING YOUR
OPPONENT UNACCEPTABLE, AND
DRIVING HIM OR HER FROM THE
PUBLIC SQUARE.
IN JUST THE PAST WEEK, WHILE
I WAS ON MY EASTER BREAK, WE
SAW MORE EXAMPLES OF THE
TOTALITARIAN AGENDA IN
ACTION.
POPULAR BLACK CONSERVATIVES
DIAMOND AND SILK NOTICED
THAT THEIR FACEBOOK FANS
WEREN'T RECEIVING
NOTIFICATIONS OF THE NEW
CONTENT THAT THEY WERE
POSTING.
FOR MONTHS, THEY BEGGED
FACEBOOK FOR ANSWERS.
WELL, ON THURSDAY, FACEBOOK
OFFICIALLY INFORMED THEM,
QUOTE:  THE POLICY TEAM HAS
COME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
YOUR CONTENT AND YOUR BRAND
HAVE BEEN DETERMINED UNSAFE
TO THE COMMUNITY.
WELL, THEY SAY THEY NEVER
INFORMED ABOUT HOW THEIR
VOIDIOS OR BRAND WERE UNSAFE
BUT THEIR FANS ARE STILL NOT
RECEIVING NOTIFICATIONS AND
FACEBOOK SAYS THERE IS NO
APPEAL.
IT FEELS LIKE WE'RE ALL,
AGAIN, IN COLLEGE.
THAT THE SPEECH POLICE
DEMAND THAT YOU CHANGE YOUR
FOCUS.
CHANGE YOUR TONE.
CHANGE THE SUBJECT.
OR ELSE.
THEN THERE WAS CONSERVATIVE
WRITER, KEVIN WILLIAMSON.
FORMERLY A NEVER TRUMPER AT
NATIONAL REVIEW.
HE WAS HIRED IN MARCH BY THE
ATLANTIC TO GREAT FANFARE.
WELL, THAT ALL CHANGED LAST
WEDNESDAY WHEN THE SOROS
FUNDED MEDIA MATTERS DOUG UP
AN OLD PODCAST WHERE
WILLIAMSON DESCRIBED
ABORTION AS HOMICIDE.
AND HE SUGGESTED THAT IT
SHOULD BE TREATED LIKE ANY
OTHER CRIME, UP TO AND
INCLUDING HANGING.
THAT'S PRETTY ROUGH STUFF
BUT SO IS ABORTION.
THE ATLANTIC EDITOR JEFFREY
GOLDBERG ANNOUNCED THAT THEY
WERE PARTING WAYS WITH
WILLIAMSON BECAUSE, QUOTE:
THE LANGUAGE USED IN THE
PODCAST WAS CALLUS AND
VIOLENT.
THIS RUNS CONTRARY TO THE
ATLANTIC'S TRADITION OF
RESPECTFUL, WELL-REASONED
DEBATE AND TO THE VALUES OF
OUR WORKPLACE.
OF COURSE, MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE THAT
ABORTION ITSELF IS CALLUS
AND VIOLENT.
MOST OBVIOUSLY TO THE
INNOCENT LIFE IT DESTROYS.
NEVERTHELESS, ANOTHER
NON-LIBERAL VOICE WAS
SNUFFED OUT AT YET ANOTHER
ESTEEMED PUBLICATION.
MY FRIENDS, SOMETHING ALARM
SOMETHING TAKING PLACE.
THE FREE SPEECH CLAUSE OF
OUR CONSTITUTION DOESN'T
JUST APPLY SPEECH THAT THE
ELITES DEEM ACCEPTABLE.
IT IS EXISTS TO SUPPORT
SPEECH THAT IS BY ITS NATURE
OFFENSIVE.
OFFENSIVE TO PEOPLE IN POWER
OFFENSIVE AT TIMES TO
LAWMAKERS.
OFFENSIVE TO FACEBOOK, AND
EVEN OFFENSIVE TO THE COOL
CROWD THAT THINKS ABORTION
IS JUST A SACRED RIGHT AND
THAT TRUMP HIMSELF IS A
DANGEROUS DICTATOR.
WE INDEED ARE REACHING A
CRISIS POINT.
WHERE CULTURAL WALLS HAVE
NOW BEING ERECTED TO
CONSCRIPT AND STEAL FREE
SPEECH IN AMERICA.
WE CANNOT LET THIS CONTINUE.
AT THE END OF TONIGHT'S
SHOW, I'M GOING TO BE
ANNOUNCING MY RESPONSE TO
THIS DANGEROUS EPIDEMIC AND
WHAT THIS SHOW WILL DO IN
THE COMING WEEKS TO EXPOSE
THE PERPETRATORS, THEIR
TACTICS, THEIR MAJOR
PLAYERS, AND THEIR FUNDERS.
THEIR EFFORTS ARE STALINIST,
PURE AND SIMPLE.
THEIR OBJECTIVE IS A TOTAL
TRANSFORMATION OF AMERICAN
SOCIETY, NOT THROUGH
RATIONAL DISCOURSE AND OPEN
DEBATE, BUT THROUGH PERSONAL
DEMONIZATION AND SILENCING.
TRUE LIBERALS AND
CONSERVATIVES SHOULD DEFEND
THE FREE SPEECH ANYWHERE AND
EVERYWHERE BECAUSE THE
TABLES CAN TURN QUICKLY.
TODAY IT'S CONSERVATIVES
BEING TARGETED.
TOMORROW IT COULD BE LEFT OF
CENTER VOICES AS WELL.
I SAY LET THE DEBATE
CONTINUE.
WHAT THE SPEECH CZARS DON'T
SEEM TO APPRECIATE IS THAT
THERE ARE AS MANY IF NOT
MORE OF US THAN THERE ARE OF
THEM.
AND WE WILL NEVER RELENT.
AND WE WILL NEVER GIVE IN.